[Musik]
und
nicht
hallo herr picard installiert werden
heute möchte ich euch zeigen wie ihr
eine richtig tolle stücke machen könnt
die man dann zum beispiel auf eine karte
setzen kann
was diese baby shower posse oder eine
ich bin schwanger forte oder was auch
immer
jedenfalls habe ich jetzt hier eine
sitzende stolz figur im video zeigen
aber auch wie man eine stehende figur
machen kann und was man tun muss damit
die weko nicht bloß sammeln fans doch
dann habe ich auf blüten plastik gemacht
weil die ebenso gut durchtrocknen und
man dann die figur eben nicht
tage vorher herstellen ich empfehle euch
trotzdem die figuren immer etwa fünf bis
sechs tage vor dem eigentlichen event zu
machen damit einfach wirklich gut
durchtrocknen kann und einfach auch
stabil genug sind und schön hart sind
die figuren werden jemals nicht
mitgegessen das heißt wenn ihr darunter
so ein kleines sport macht kann man die
figur auch auf die torte setzen und der
oder die beschenkte dann bequem und
einfach aufheben
ich würde sagen gelingen ist einfach los
geht's mit der basis dass sie kurz damit
die stiko richtig schön transportieren
kann und auch drauf arbeiten kann und
natürlich später auch ganz einfach auf
die torte setzen kann
brauche ich eine grundlage dafür nämlich
flöten passte auch für die figur später
weil blüten passte einfach super schnell
trocknet und ich muss deswegen die figur
ist nicht fünf tage vorher machen
sondern ein zwei tage vorher reicht
vollkommen aus
nämlich weiße blüten passte sie habe ich
bereits weiß geknetet und rolle tri mit
hilfe von 22 künstlern auf einem
zentimeter stärke aus mit einem
ausstecher da war oder zum beispiel
einem glas oder einem teller kann ich
das ganze rund ausschneiden oder auch
aus städten die basis kann jetzt erstmal
trocknung ich habe zehn kickboard so
kann ich sie besser transportieren und
ihr könnt auch um den ganzen vorgang im
wissen zu beschleunigen
den backofen an machen und zwar auf
umluft der trocknet der immer schön
alles aus die temperatur sollte nicht
mehr als 30 grad haben damit der zucker
einfach nicht schnell und so kann man
den ganzen vorgang getrockneten ein
bisschen beschleunigen so mache ich es
auch gleich stellte gleich in den
backofen und in dieser zeit kann ich
mich jetzt schon mal um die stars
gemacht
als nächstes ist es bei storch an der
reihe und war vor mit dem kopf und den
körper
beide teile werden rund er guckt hat es
etwa einen durchmesser von dreieinhalb
zentimeter und der körper habe einen
durchmesser von etwa 5 bis 5,5
zentimeter
wichtig ist dass die blüten passt ganz
weiß geknetet wird und dann wirklich
faltenfrei zusammengerottet und damit
das ganze ein bisschen einfacher geht
fertig die hände immer wieder mit kaufen
[Musik]
zum antrocknen lege ich die kugel mit
ein kleines schirmchen rein
ich bin ein bisschen vor reformen für
das die kugel ist einfach nicht flach
gedrückt wird sondern schön rot bleibe
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich ein kleines vermögen havel
und färbe ist mit lebensmittel verpasste
in gelb und rot in zartes orange ein
[Musik]
aus einem 15 zentimeter großen wahl
werde ich jetzt im stolzen fussball und
war vom die denn zuerst einmal zu einem
tropfen dann hinlegen und leicht flach
drücken
jetzt zeige ich mir den fuß ein also
einmal hier mittel
[Musik]
und hier oben nochmal zum kleinen daumen
der nach hinten gebogen wird werden die
finger nicht aber es seien beschlüsse
einfach mit den fingern geformt
[Musik]
und als nächstes mache ich jetzt das
kleine feine rillen rein und das können
sie entweder mit seiner modelle weg
machen oder auch einen liefern damit sie
nur auffassung dass die bilder nicht
abschneiden sondern wirklich noch
[Musik]
sind beide füße fertig ich bearbeite
teil wird doch immer mit welcher stärke
zum aufrollen zum beispiel oder auch um
etwas ab die beispielsweise freuen auch
die kugel und die becker steige bekommt
ihr ganz einfach mit einem pinsel direkt
also entweder trocken ab oder oder ein
bisschen den kokosfett tauchen und dann
ab oder da geht einfach dermaßen schnell
wieder weg diese sind jetzt erst mal
fertig jetzt sind die beine an der reihe
und damit das stolz aufstehen kann muss
ich die beine natürlich stabilisieren
das finde ich jetzt hier so viel wie
sticks und pepsi gleich hier reinstecken
und die werden dann eben auf diese basis
gesteckt und das war wirklich gut stehen
kann
die logistics diesen ersten 20 meter
lauf und jetzt hat sich wieder ein
bisschen rausnehmen
[Musik]
und doch alle jetzt die orangefarbene
blüten hatte erst mal schön aus
[Musik]
finale bestreitet nicht dass es war
das habe ich hier oben so etwa zwei
zentimeter frei
der teil muss man im schweizer in den
körper rein gesteckt
[Musik]
und vielleicht einen schmalen streifen
zurecht und wickelt sehen dann um den
sieg
[Musik]
hier und auch kein bisschen platt weil
der teil eben in den verein gesteckt
wird und falls ihr einen überrest ab
könnte den einfach mit einer schere
wegschneiden und die nähte dann mit
peter zug blieb und auch die beine
bekommen diese typischen rede und das
mache ich mir damit dem modellwechsel
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich ein bein und den körper
und weil es erst einmal markieren wo die
füße hinkommen und die sollen einfach
mittels hinkommen damit die füße dem
körper eben auch stabil auffangen können
einstecken
jetzt muss ich den abstand zwischen
beiden löchern auslaufen
das ist bei mir von der mitte aufgesägt
1,5 zentimeter und kann nicht mehr die
spitze schon mal platzieren
ein bisschen weiter nach hinten weil
vorne nämlich noch ein baby platz haben
soll
und hier muss ich schon auf etwa 1 zu
machen zentimeter und wenn das dann
passte einfach mit essbarem kleber
angekommen
[Musik]
jetzt wollen die bayern noch in die
füsse reingesteckt und auch mit kritik
[Musik]
und das war der kleber fest wird kann
ich jetzt einmal kontrollieren ob passt
wunderbar
das kann ich die teile für etwa eine
halbe stunde bis stunde erst einmal
antrocknen lassen kann ich jetzt nutzen
um den kopf weiter zu modellieren
dafür habe ich jetzt hier ein kleines
stück orange das werdet nämlich dass
schnabel
das heißt den mieter zu einem langen
tropfenform kann sich hinten ein
bisschen platt drücken
und was so dass oben wie so eine art
bäume entsteht
[Musik]
hab ich den schnabel abgelegt haben mit
er unten so ein bisschen flach geformtes
und kann hier oben diese weiter aus
formen und dann im prinzip schon
ankleben
[Musik]
hier oben gibt noch keine löcher
eingedrückt und das mache ich jetzt mit
einem kleinen boot holen
[Musik]
weil das mal ein bisschen angetrocknet
ist kann ich hier an der seite auch mit
einem kleinen messer oder eine
modellierung linie ein zeichen so dass
es eben zwei schnabel helfen soll auf
einem hellblauen stück blüten passe form
ich jetzt noch den postboten hoch und 20
dafür das kleine stück wurde und formen
so eine scharfe kante zurecht und vorne
kommt dann noch ein kleines 5 dran
während der mut noch an trocknet kann
ich die augen modellieren darf ich jetzt
hier weiße und blaue blüten passte und
die blaue habe ich ein minimal dunkler
gefärbt damit sich einfach die farben
und sind voneinander abheben streichen
sinclair und setzte zwei kleine weiße
kugel hin
[Musik]
und die werde jetzt mit einem werkzeug
und eingedrückt jemals eine kleine blaue
kugel rein
[Musik]
jetzt bekommt die straße müsste noch
eine kleine botschaft hier vorne trägt
ein weißes drauf und mal mit einem roten
lebensmittel farbstift ein herzchen
drauf
[Musik]
nachdem die teile des storches ist an
getrocknet sind werden sie jetzt
verbunden
das heißt der bauch kommt jetzt auf die
beine bevor ich den bauch aber drauf
klebe habe ich jetzt aus weißer blüten
passte bei keine würstchen geformt und
es werden jetzt die verbindungsstücke
die gebe ich jetzt auch die oz und beine
auf und dann wird mit kleber der bauch
wird zum stabilisieren habe ich hier
noch zwei kleine würstchen gesorgt und
die hierhin geklebt und auch eingraviert
und hier hinten habe ich eine tafel
hingestellt damit der ganze etwas
stabilität und dadurch trocknen so lange
kann ich mich schon mal um baby kümmern
das geht sie auch ganz einfach da jetzt
etwas orange und weiß gemusterten
apricot ton entsteht und david mc google
drauf das wird er kocht man sieht auch
nur den kopf des babys
dann ein minimales kleines mädchen und
am nächsten mittwoch kleber befestigt
mit einer luft element ist die augen
noch andeuten
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt die große seite und
damit ich den mund und vlies aussieht
leben
[Musik]
und dann natürlich auch noch einen
schnuller und wem werde ich jetzt auch
rover modelle schokolade formen einen
teil der module schokolade habe ich es
bringt eingefärbte andere drahtlose und
da muss ich zwei kleine kugeln machen
und sie es auf den muskel
[Musik]
ein fallrohr seiner modelle schokolade
schon ausgerollt noch nicht ganz denn da
nimmt jetzt eine struktur rolle und
raunheimer skipper und es wird tore und
damit dass lediglich
[Musik]
um die restliche und formt daraus beiden
körper aber den sieg einfach formen und
proportionen und herr johnson baby passt
jetzt noch umdrehen
lecker stärke könnte immer ganz einfach
weg und dann glaube ich jetzt hier ein
und ein kleber unten und oben drauf
hier kommt jetzt noch weg körper rein
[Musik]
und dann wird das tuch unten geklappt
und an den seiten verbund
[Musik]
der körper des streifens ist immer
angetrocknet sich stabilisieren trotzdem
weiterhin mit der taste und jetzt muss
ich natürlich auch noch den halb formen
denn den kopf wenn die erst morgen drauf
lassen so dass er wirklich komplett
durchgetrocknet um den hals zu
stabilisieren braucht jetzt einen schlag
weg spielt bin habe ich bereits ein
bisschen gekürt das heißt sie natürlich
vorstellen ein fall muss in den körper
rein zeit in den kopf und ein fall wird
eben da halt ganz laden schon abgemacht
mit um geschlossen so hoch und jetzt
möchte ich hier ein lokal machen was
mache ich jetzt erstmal mit dem
zahnstocher bei der zahnstocher minimal
dünner ist und dann hab ich gleich ein
bisschen einfacher möglich ansetzen und
dann wirklich nur minimal nach vorne
sodass das schwerpunkt also nicht so
sehr vorne links sondern erst mit
da kommt jetzt ein bisschen kleber rein
und dann das schafft
herzstück ist ein längeres geformt schau
mal ob von der länge her paar minimal
muss ich noch kürzen
jetzt habe ich schon die form des hauses
sowie die auch sein sollten einfach ein
bisschen ein klapp den hals auf
bereinigt um den schacht xii
es war so dass die nazis
[Musik]
an dem streifen kauft gebe ich jetzt
noch ein paar haare also und peter und
da noch die meiste an und dann können
die sachen im prinzip über nacht trocken
und morgen
[Musik]
am nächsten tag setzt sich jetzt den
stolz zusammen
dafür nehme ich wieder etwas essbaren
kleber und befahren flügel noch
drankommen werde ich im sturm sind farbe
geben etwas pulver farbe
die könnt ihr wenn ihr möchtet mit
alkohol fördern und noch mal die beine
und den schnabel an waren und für baby
tragetuch nämlich jetzt einfach ein
bisschen flüssige farbe und manche tun
[Musik]
die füße farben gibt natürlich auch auf
blüten hatte mich bereits dünn
ausgerollt und west tropfenförmig zu
schneiden
sie werden wissen eingeschritten
und dann mit den fingern und
[Musik]
sie lacht jetzt hier einfach ein
bisschen runter damit vielleicht an
trocknen können und es gibt dann mit
kleber ankleben jetzt quasi per ad hoc
erst wollte ich muss an meinem start
weiter museum aber es ist leider
passiert das steuer ist ungebrochen
das lag leider an verschiedenen dingen
ich kann mich auch sagen
zum einen waren belegt text einfach zu
dünn aber geht schon hatte ich damit
keine anderen sie ist einfach aber du
bist gar nicht schlimm sowas kann
passieren auch kurz vor ende
und deswegen ist es einfach nur ganz
wichtig was sie braucht macht ich werde
euch zeigen wie man einen sitzenden
strich macht das heißt das ganze hier
kenne ich erstmal weg stellen es kommt
jetzt wächst den körper der ist gut aber
den habe ich jetzt weg genommen und vom
kopf den kopf weil ich weiter verwenden
und zeige euch jetzt einfach wie wir
einen sitzenden stock modellieren kann
passieren es ganz bestimmt ob doch erst
jetzt machen wir die sitzen des student
körper aus einem stück des fcz jetzt
eine kugel geformt und vor mit ihr den
hals
wer jetzt schon lang im körper ständiges
kurz zur seite
und hier habe ich noch mal diese
unterlage bereits ausgestochen und die
werde ich jetzt mit diesen zwei farben
des impulses fahren einfach am besten
[Musik]
jetzt hätte ich den stoff körper hier
drauf warum jetzt singh kleber und jetzt
nämlich einen langen versteckspiel
steckt ihn einmal durch und deswegen
habe ich jetzt das ganze auch erhöht und
auf einem abkühlte
denn so kann ich den start komplett auf
den boden setzen die torte ist ja auch
hoch genug bist später stecke ich das
ganze einfach mit dem start in die torte
schreiben und wir werden dann hier in
einem kleinen winkel dran gebracht
o
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich den kopf auf den stoff
also mit bisschen kleber einfach
diktieren draufgesetzt und wenn ihr
möchtet könnt ihr gerne noch die flügel
des storches von leichen schwappte markt
und alles ist einfach nur das müsse
genehmigt werden
[Musik]
die stiko fertig und sie gefällt nur
auch richtig gut
idealerweise lassen sie jetzt etwas vier
bis fünf tage trocknen wird er einfach
schön hart und fest und kann einfach
nichts mehr passieren und wichtig ist
aber dass ihr sie nicht im kühlschrank
aufbewahrt sondern an einem trockenen
ort am besten den abstand kammer
leichter abdecken mit einem karton zum
beispiel so dass er einfach nicht
geschützt ist und die farbe neben dann
auch nicht verblassen
die figur ist im prinzip dann auch
wirklich ewig haltbar also ich hatte mal
von ihrer figuren zu ihrem ersten
geburtstag gemacht und hab mir glaube
ich wirklich vier jahre aufgehoben
irgendwann hab ich gedacht kommen dass
ein staubfänger jetzt doch am liebsten
weg also nicht am liebsten aber studiert
am reck und deswegen ich könnte wirklich
aus bewahren aber einfach staubgeschützt
lagern und so werde ich mir dann einfach
auf meine steuerte setzen
ich hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen
trotz der kleinen panne zwischendurch
aber wie gesagt plan b ist das
wichtigste was ihr drauf macht und ich
wünsche euch jetzt ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen
schaut euch auf jeden fall auf die
straße an also die baby shower posse
ich hoffe dass die euch genauso groß
gefeiert also viel spaß und zunächst
[Musik]
do